(phone buzzing)
- [Liz's Mom] Hi, Liz, this is mommy.
It's that time of year again, Christmas.
I didn't want you to make the
trip all the way home again
so this year I'll be visiting you!
I just got off the plane and got my bags.
I'm going to take a taxi to your place
so if you're not home, well,
I remember where you hid
the key, so I'll be fine.
Can't wait to see you.
Love you, bye.
- Where's the other bag?
- Hallway closet!
- Shit, don't forget my
dirty clothes in the basket.
- That's all you.
- Hey, babe?
Can't you just tell your mom
that you're really into
gaming or something?
- Get that shit outta here!
(uptempo percussion music)
Did we get everything?
- You mean expunge me out of your life?
I think so.
- She's about to be here.
Just go, I'm sorry.
I'll call you later, okay?
- Wait, we can't spend
the holidays together?
- I don't know.
We'll figure it out.
Bye.
(sighing)
(atmospheric music)
- I'm really excited for
this position because
I love learning new things and
I love working with others.
I love learning new skills and I work well
with other people and I
love helping other people.
I am people's person.
I believe that I can make
a great contribution to your company.
I'm very familiar with
what your company does.
I'm flexible, energetic, and
have a positive attitude.
I'm seeking to become
an expert in this field,
in this position, at this job.
It has been my dream since I was little
to sell insurance for your stupid company
because I want to stay here.
(breathing heavy)
- Devin, there's no easy way to do this.
Your work has been great
but we just can't meet the
minimum salary required
to sponsor you anymore.
And I know the holidays are coming up
and the timing is bad as shit,
but we've added a little severance,
you know just something
to help get you over.
Look, you're a smart guy.
There's a company out there that you're
gonna be the perfect fit for.
You're gonna be like the
Lego that's been missing
between the couch cushions
for god knows how long.
You're gonna be good, don't worry.
(phone buzzing)
I'm gonna just crash at your place.
- Nah.
Remember she threw a bowl
over me last weekend?
I had to carry her ass all
the way to her apartment.
I'm good.
Call me later?
- I'll talk to you later then.
(loud slurping)
(whimsical music)
(phone buzzing)
How long's your break, two weeks?
- I don't care.
I fucking hate dental school.
I hate teeth.
I hate it more than my period.
- One more semester and you settle in.
- Settle in for what?
Looking at rotting teeth every
day for the next 30 years?
I'm not gonna wake up one day
and realize the season had
passed on me pulling teeth.
There's not gonna be any looking back.
No one on their deathbed goes,
"I should've fixed teeth."
Fucking threw my life away.
- At least you have an opportunity.
I worked my ass off
for the last five years
and I still cannot live in this country.
You're basically crying
'cause the sky is too blue.
- I thought your company
is sponsoring your H-1B?
What?
Why, what happened?
Right before Christmas too.
What are you gonna do?
- Find a different job.
Marry a U.S. citizen.
- Hey,
if you want,
I could totally marry you and
have an anchor baby with you.
Yeah, we'll show them what's
up and have a fucking baby!
And we'll be like, hey, look
at our American baby, bitch!
( light jazz music)
(whimsical music)
(heavy breathing)
(phone buzzing)
(chattering)
♪ Wishes come true the
same time every year ♪
♪ When every night twinkles
and you're filled with cheer ♪
♪ Since long, long ago
we've been hoping for snow ♪
♪ As we cuddle the whole night through ♪
♪ On the night when dreams come true ♪
♪ Songs will be sung and
we'll join with loved ones ♪
♪ To celebrate to new ♪
♪ On the night when dreams come true ♪
- Hi, I'm Claire.
("Jingle Bells")